everest is it's a big misconception for
some people because a lot of people
think that because of the amount of
people that go up and
calibre of people that go up it's an
easy thing to do and coming from someone
who's done
a lot of difficult things in their life
everest is by no means
an easy feat it just seems to attract
people who can afford it because it
comes with a
very high price tag and you do end up
with a lot of dross on the mountain
which doesn't give it a very good
reputation
it's six weeks of living at altitude if
you stand up and walk
10 meters at sea level it's fine right
you don't think about it
but if you're a six seven thousand
meters in the sky and you stand up and
walk 10 meters you're taking a couple of
steps
stopping breathing taking a couple of
steps stopping breathing
so like everything that you deemed easy
at sea level
is magnified in difficulty the further
up you go
jay welcome to the show how's it going
chris you good
very well i'm in dubai how could i not
be well i do need to hold my hands up
for everyone that is watching on youtube
yes i'm wearing a vest yes i caught a
little bit of sun today tiny little bit
just a bit flush right but i haven't
seen sunshine for like
six months so give me a break i've also
got you currently jay you're balanced on
an upturned bin
uh in my hotel room and i'm doing this
after tethering to my phone on
roaming data so god knows how much this
is gonna cost but it's more than worth
it so thank you very much for coming on
man
it's too easy yeah you never see what's
in the background do you have what
you've got
okay man where you've just got to
balance your phone and and
whatever's going on in the background so
yeah absolute chaos
right it's just you're a northerner too
you're a fellow northerner so don't do
well in the sun
look i i've got two ginger parents but
thankfully i don't think i've fully
inherited their skin
but you're totally right man when you're
from winterfell you you don't tan
don't talk exactly well you just you go
white you just seem to go white
yeah that leads me quite nicely into
talking about the temperature leads me
quite nicely into something i wanted to
ask which is which is more difficult the
selection process for special forces
or climbing everest twice um
i'd have to say climbing everest um
selection you know six months essay
selection just seems to
it's drawn out over six months right and
when you start you're already a
you're already a seasoned soldier like
for me i've done one tour
of iraq and two tours of afghanistan so
you
almost get to that stage where you you
you want to prove yourself as
as a soldier and i was you know 24 years
old
like full of testosterone um
so like you go on selection with a bunch
of other lads and you're all
you know you've got this unified kind of
cause that you're all trying to that
you're all going for at the same time
and i actually enjoyed selection for
that reason
um because you meet you know you you end
up
all that you know you start with maybe
150 170 people
after the first three weeks you kind of
down to 50
and then after the next six weeks you
you kind of down to maybe
20 25 people and these 20 25 people have
been through through absolute [ __ ] so
you end up forming this like super tight
bond where
you're all really close and and all
really clicky and then
you get to the end of selection after
that six months you get given
your stable belt and your beret
and you get like a picture tuck uh next
to the clock tower
you shake everyone's hand and then you
disappear into whatever regiment and
squadrons that you go to
and then the next day you kind of big
boys rules into the
into the mix thrown into the lines then
yeah and i remember i remember turning
up day one and
like i was 24 like it's quite a young
age to pass election
and um like the rest of the guys in my
troop were all kind of
i mean some of them were touching 40
years old so it's a 24 year old turning
into
turning up into this this sas troop with
a load of 40 year olds
even like the guy who came in two years
before me he was like
you know two three years ahead of me and
uh
like they're all like big guys like big
kind of
men with like gray hair and stuff and
big hands massive hands
massive hands like you know we had
billy was one of our um one of our
senior sergeants at the time and
you know he was like uh you know x
x kind of football hooligan from london
and just covered in like skull tattoos
and
and uh like flames of his arms very
welcoming like
yeah we we actually went to norway on
our first exercise and i ended up
spending it
spending the whole uh six weeks living
in a tent with him
so yeah we got on quite well very cozy
after a while yeah
yeah as it turns out he was the nicest
guy there that's awesome man
yeah and how does that relate to everest
then
yeah so like everest is
everest is like quite a big it's a big
misconception for some people
um because a lot of people think that
because of the amount of people that go
up and
and the caliber of people that go up
it's an easy thing to do
and coming from someone who's done a lot
of difficult things in their life
everest is by no means an easy feat
it just seems to attract people who can
afford it because it comes with a
very high price tag so it kind of
attracts a certain
caliber of people and you do end up with
a lot of
a lot of dross on the mountain which
doesn't give it a very
uh good reputation but everest is more
it's six weeks of
living at altitude so if you think like
altitude just basically takes away
energy from you so if you stand up and
walk
10 meters at sea level it's fine right
you don't think about it but if you're a
you know six seven thousand meters in
the sky and you stand up and walk ten
meters
you know you're taking a couple of steps
stopping breathing
taking a couple of steps stopping
breathing so like everything that you
deemed
easy at sea level is magnified in
difficulty
the further up you go to the point of
on your summit push when you know if you
think of your summit push it's quite
just to give a picture of of kind of the
severity of it
you do like in a client you get up to
base camp you do an acclimatization
which
takes five days or six days you come
back down you rest at base camp
which is at 5 600 meters and then
you kind of sit there and look at the
weather windows
um and you get you always get one
weather window to summer which is clear
skies you know
minimal winds you sometimes get two
weather windows
and you rarely get three so it's this
balance of
looking at all your weather weather
systems and speaking to the light people
around the camps and finding out what's
going on
because like you've invested all this
time right you've invested like the last
three weeks of living at altitude eating
[ __ ] food um you know [ __ ] into a
hole in the ground
every morning a frozen frozen hole in
the ground
like you lit it's like clockwork every
morning and
you know your only entertainment is the
game of cards that you play at night in
the tent
by this time you're sick of lunch and
meat and rice
so you invested all this energy and time
into
making the right decision and getting to
the you know getting
high up and something in the in the
right weather window because if you
don't that's it you know
you only get one shot at summit and then
you kind of set off at camp three
on your summit push so you'll leave camp
three which is
seven thousand meters and there's four
camps till summer so you go
camp three seven thousand meters leave
there at five am
on oxygen you climb up to camp four
arrive at camp four
say four pm so that's a full day to get
there
camp 4 is 8 000 meters so you rest there
in a tent for you know six hours
you try and get some sleep you get some
hot water on you
cook some food and then you leave that
night at 8 p.m to summer
for first light so you know 6am 7am in
the morning
and then you've got all that day to come
all the way back down to camp two
which you get to camp to it say
like i got there about 9 p.m so
it's a 15-hour day at ridiculous
altitude
yeah so you start five a.m it's like two
days basically just constantly
with no sleep minimal water
um at that altitude your body doesn't
work the same so you don't
digest food um so i was literally living
off
like the little energy sachets that like
cyclists and triathletes and that use
which obviously then you know i ended up
with that just all over my hands just
like
sticky and it just leaks out into your
pockets every time you put your hand in
your pocket your hand gets stuck um
you're not drinking as much water just
because you're constantly needing to
move and
kind of beyond camp four up to the
summer
it it's your body's kind of that
drained and tired and exhausted
it's simply just that one foot in front
of the other that slow
kind of monotonous like tap
tap tap and then you kind of you just
see everyone doing it everyone kind of
puts their art like
their elbows on the legs and like
because you're on like a steep hill and
just
just gives it like a few couple of puffs
of breath and just
composes themselves before they set off
again
um and then you get to the top and then
coming down to even worse because it's
steep ground
and that you've got this this mass of
people are coming down at the same time
so you
you know you're trying to work your way
through all these people for like the
next
for the next 17 so you summit 6 a.m
i'm not i'm no good at math something at
6 00 a.m get back down for 10 p.m
so what's that 16 14 hours of
walking downhill where your toes are
just hitting the front of your boots for
14 hours
to the point you know you start walking
sideways
you start walking back backwards yeah
you just like like i've been exhausted
and tired and like fatigued and
so many times in like a military career
but like you're never that
fatigued and exhausted that you are on
everest
it seems like a big part of that is the
camaraderie that you had in the support
structure
from when you were doing special forces
selection
i guess as well like if you've in thin
air
and it's really cold and you're on a
thin ridge
it's like first off you spread out
second you've got to save your breath to
be able to focus on the few
bodily functions that your physiology is
still
able to do whereas as you said during
your special
special forces you're really able you've
got this sort of unity that that
binds you all together and makes maybe
the suffering a little bit less
uh solo yeah a little bit i think
you know for a start you're at sea level
so that makes things way easier
um yeah like
i guess when you're at sea level and
you're doing the things that you're
doing in the special forces
you always know where the end is and the
end's usually quite comfortable
so say you're deploying an operation
that is
anything from you know 10 hours 12 hours
on a night raid or you go out for a week
and live in a building and put an open
or whatever it is
and you always know at the end of that
you take enough food you take enough
water you know you you're warm
you're taking enough um you know
sleeping equipment or enough jackets and
warm clothing that
you're gonna be you're gonna be
semi-comfortable right there might be a
little bit hardship you might be walking
in with
some some weight in some kit you do the
job you extract or whatever it is
um but you know at the end of that week
actually unless the job or mission
changes
you're gonna come back to base or
wherever it is that you you live whether
you're in the uk you come back you're
probably you know having beers with the
boys
at the weekend or whatever or if it's if
you're overseas you know you're coming
back to a camp you do kitten
you go for steak and eggs in the morning
you're gonna get back in the gym
um whereas like on everest it's like you
set off on that summit window
and and that rotation on that summit
window is seven days
so you leave base camp
you leave base camp with a rucksack and
you come back in seven days with that
same rucksack
and um and you you know you're not
coming back to steak and eggs
and beers are the boys and a warm shower
you're literally i mean you know you
come back to a hot water
you know hot bucket of water and a a
little bit of leftover like shampoo that
you touch it's a slightly bigger
slightly bigger hole in the ground to
have a poop yeah
well everyone's just been like filling
it in once you've been gone so it's like
overflowing oh no
no no no no please make it stop
um it's not like that hotel room in
dubai until yeah this is
it is lovely out here so we're talking
about your new book today which
will be out when this episode is live
what does respect is earned
mean um so kind of the book is just
you know it's it's to just say like this
is my
14 years of military experience and the
special forces and the paras
and i've just put all that knowledge and
experience into the book
and it's it's essentially that right
it's read this book and respect his own
it's like do the hard stuff through
my military career and it's like that is
how you gain respect
i understand let's go through the four
tenets of the special forces i thought
this was really interesting yeah
yeah so um so you got relentless pursuit
for excellence
um so that is you know if you think of
like
values that you live your life by the
special forces has those and
first ones relentless pursuit of
excellence and you know it should be
something that we should be
searching for every day within the
special forces whether it's
whatever we're doing whether it's
shooting we're always trying to get
better at shooting
whether it's you know surveillance ops
whatever it is that we're doing
we need to always be searching for that
level of excellence
and like obviously you never get to that
low you know you never get to that
level that is excellence but that
constant progression of just keep
chipping away at whatever it is you're
doing whether it's in the gym whether
it's
at home whether it's whatever it is to
just be a better human being and better
in the job that you're doing
and that's kind of the first one uh the
second one is
uh honor and humility so
um kind of humility is a massive one in
the in the special forces
um you know it's i mean
even like i remember bumping into a load
of
uh sbs lads when i was in the paris and
the first thing that
came across was you know you had these
these guys they were
they were men they were like 40 odd
years old like big dudes and that
but they were like the soundest guys
ever
and they came and found us looked after
us we played volleyball and they bought
us a load of beers and
um do you know just that it doesn't
matter what you do in your career and
where you've been it's like you still
have that humble approach which will
keep you
hungry and will keep you always wanting
to improve
and then honor is you know as it says
it's it's
having honoring what you do and honor of
the people that you work with and
honor of the job that you're doing um
and then discipline discipline goes
without saying
um it is you know
it's one of the most important things
that a soldier needs to have is
discipline
you know it's it's no um
hidden secret that you know soldiers
are people that or if you're on a job or
on a
task you're getting up early you're
doing things that
aren't necessarily comfortable things to
do um
or aren't very natural things to do
and that requires a lot of discipline a
lot of self-discipline
um to be you know to be that that best
cohesive team unit that you can be
um i've had a mind slip what's the
fourth one
i haven't got the written down mate so
we we can leave it at three we can leave
it at three
i think what is the fourth one where is
the fourth column there is
yeah we'll leave it at three three it is
now that's back to it the fourth one is
obviously not that important
i also changed it yeah this is the new
this is the jay morton
version of the the fortnite um i didn't
realize
that the sas was split up into four
squadrons with four troops within each
can you just take us through how this
works and the personalities that you
explain about that
um yeah so you've got kind of different
teams within um any special forces unit
um and then those teams are broken down
into
into individual skill sets um and kind
of the skill sets are
air so anything that is um in the air so
helicopters
mainly kind of parachuting and being a
subject matter expert in parachuting um
boats or anything that's that's to do
with water um
and then you've got mobility which is
land vehicles so
motorbikes quads off-road vehicles
four by fours all that kind of stuff and
then you've got mountain which is what i
was
which is anything to do with the
mountains
um so above the snow line so you've got
kind of arctic warfare and
you know stuff in kind of you know the
scandinavian countries that kind of
stuff and then
that kind of filters over into kind of a
a more like a rope work kind of
um like a rope access kind of thing to
try and
not put too much detail on it if that
makes sense
to try and keep it as bland as possible
as that
i understand
what's the coolest operation that you
can tell us about
um do you know like
i don't know like coolest is probably
like the not not the word i'd use but
like
there's a few that really stick out and
a few things that i
kind of ticked off whilst i was serving
again i can't i can't talk about but um
there was one
one job on a on an ied factory it was
it was a daytime raid on a night so an
ied is an improvised explosive device
um so it's it's like a homemade bomb
that the um the enemy would use against
us
so um it could be anything so it would
be anything that is
homemade and they'd you know the the
main way of using it would be sticking
it in a
in the ground covering it with dirt you
walk over it blows up
um and we hit
a factory that was that was making these
on a mass scale
um i kind of don't i kind of don't want
to go too much into the detail like
curse because it's um i understand
operational
secrecy yeah yeah we basically had nine
guys on it
and it was anything it almost reminded
me of like a crazy western movie
um when we kind of landed the
helicopters uh next to the compound and
um i was with a team of afghans and we
we come running off the back of this
helicopter and a few of the few other
guys from the factory just
like legged it from the factory and um
they took their chances and just like
ran and um
i was like first man out there there's
only like i think there's only a few of
us
um a few of us uh british
and um these afghans just started firing
over my head
and i literally just i could feel like
bullets just whizzing past me actually
just
literally turned around and said stop
firing
and just shoot one of us
it was it was like a crazy western film
um but now that was do you know what
that sticks out was one of the ones one
of the best jobs i did
probably because the impact it had on on
the local air
in terms of you know the ied the numbers
of iuds that were hitting
british troops that were operating in
the area when substantially down
um and we got you know nine of the the
guys that were making these
um ieds at the same time so that for me
sticks out
massively there's a few others that i
won't go into too much detail about
yeah i understand the mod wouldn't be
happy but that
it's so cool to see where um when
the special forces are deployed to cut
off at the knees
an operation which obviously down the
line will be hurting
local afghans it will be meant to attack
other british forces and and other
foreign sort of forces that are out
there
so yeah i can totally see why that would
be something that you'd be proud of
another one again this might be an mod
dance around
when we're the most scared during your
service is there anything that comes to
mind which you can tell us about
um probably when those bullets are
flying
that's perfect
one of those weird things when you when
you're operating in that kind of
environment
um and it like it can it can come and go
like the most randomest of times and and
you generally
you know you go over c's for six months
at a time and
you know after after a while you almost
you almost
you change how you deal with things in
your own head
you find like ways of just coping with
whatever's going on and i don't mean
that in a negative way
if anything it's a positive way um but
you kind of just
like fear doesn't really appear as much
as
i don't know you go you could go through
like a because like
soldiers are really good at coping with
fear with
with humor um and a lot of
some of the scariest moments that
that i would say are the scariest
moments right if you took a normal
person through
through them in that situation like you
seem to cope very well with it with with
a lot of humor
and um yeah i can remember kind of
a few times when and this was going back
to kind of my days in the parachute
regiment in three power and
you know i remember one day when we just
got opened up on and
you know you're almost seeing you're
seeing like rounds hitting like
walls and the floor around way where you
are and
you know whether it's you know the
taliban didn't have the the weapon zero
that day or
you know something else was looking
after you
you know you don't end up with a bullet
in you um
but you're so close to it um
and there's you know there's a few
situations like that but again it's like
you know we just got you know when that
happened we got opened up on
in you know point blank range we
literally just ran around this corner
and just all started laughing
at each other
i don't know it's like whether there's a
lesson there that
you know the best way of just dealing
with fear is just with humor
and it's like you know it's like one of
those reactions right of
something happens and like people
instantly smile and it's like you
you know if you if you look at that
situation you probably shouldn't be
smiling
but you do you just you just seem to
laugh about it
i know i wonder what it is i wonder
whether fear
and humor are somewhere along the same
sort of line
but there's a bit of an archetype there
right you know the
the crazy soldier
who is able to laugh off pat but it was
a scratch you know like that kind of
like classic
stiff upper lip british thing yeah like
like i've seen some like i've seen lads
get shot
and they're just laughing and smiling
and probably
happier than they would be if they
hadn't have been shot what
like not not not on impact right and you
i might have
you know because like everything happens
quite fast in
in fight and combat right you generally
you know if you think how fast around
flies and as soon as that goes out the
gun it's straight into someone's body
and that's a very quick
um situation to happen so then
i don't have time for fear to evolve so
you're thinking like [ __ ] right i'm
going to grab this guy drag him into
some cover
sort him out administer first aid and
then we need to we need to extract him
extract him back to a like a point where
he could be picked up
and taken to safety and
be seen by like a proper medical
professional um
so like there's no time there for fear
to overcome if that makes sense
um so yeah it's like
but yeah i've seen kind of you know even
even guys that have lost limbs and i
don't mean on impact when it's happened
but
you know you've got to be able to to
deal with it with humor
and um i actually remember one incident
um i won't go to too much detail about
it but
um one of the guys ended up getting a
shotgun through his knee
um by accident and um
like ruined him like probably you know
you know made a mess of this guy's
career
and um i remember everyone just started
taking the piss out of him
the guy that accidentally discharged the
shotgun into this guy's knee
and i remember chatting to him i think
we're in a car driving
driving to london or something and i was
chatting to him and he was like i
thought like
you know how'd you feel about it
whatever and he's like the best thing
that
that happened was that people took the
piss out of him
he was like if no one took the piss out
of me then
i would have felt that i've done
something seriously wrong
because everyone's just took the piss
out of me and like
made jokes and sent out you know memes
and
and pictures on um on whatsapp groups
like i fee i just feel like better about
the whole situation
there's uh examples similar to that that
i had with seth godin so i was recording
with him a couple of weeks ago
and similar to today with you having a
nightmare with connections he needed to
change
his and i needed to change mine and
we're on a really tight time schedule as
well
and he did so he made such a classy move
when we came back on
so after all of the connections had gone
out and then we logged back onto the
call and we were about to get going
when we first called him before he even
said hello is everything sorted or
anything he just told me a joke
like a really [ __ ] dad joke like awful
awful like totally terrible
but any any tension between me and a 20
times best-selling
author and marketing hall of fame member
seth godin this
absolute titan of internet fame
was gone in a second so i definitely
think that there's there's an
interesting lesson to take away from
that like the use that humor has
for all of us especially to dissuade
pressure
and tension and and fear you know before
someone's about to go on stage to give a
good speech a big speech or
before you're about to go and uh do a
pitch or a job interview or perform
or you know do anything i i think that
there's
definitely an argument to be made that
if you've got a couple of
[ __ ] jokes in your pocket that you can
just
deploy on demand i reckon that they
would be really useful
but it's it's so true right and it you
know they do
they do say that like the cleverest
people have the highest iqs
not sorry the funniest people there's a
there's a correlation between like
clever people and
funny funny people absolutely um that's
why i'm not there but um
but yeah there is there's there's
definitely
because like we're all the same person
right we all
eat we all [ __ ] we all do all that stuff
and
you get i don't know you build that
perception it's like you might have had
with seth
um you put them on you put people like
that on a pedestal and it's like
it's like we're all just the same person
and you know we can all tell a [ __ ] dad
joke
[Laughter]
my dad my dad absolutely can okay so the
book the book's called soldier and
that's an acronym for a bunch of bunch
of things that go underneath it the
first one being self
and you call discipline the first
effective habit have you got any tips on
how people can cultivate their
discipline
obviously we're in the middle in the uk
at least of a brand new lockdown and
people may be thinking this is a time
where i can either let my habits go one
of two ways
what can people do to cultivate that
discipline
yeah like it's quite important now right
during the second lockdown phase that
like i said you know i had this thought
during the first lockdown phase that
like i'm not gonna let this time just
waste just waste away and slip out under
me
and you know all i can say that i've
done done during lockdown was
watch some netflix documentaries and and
um
and box sets and and that's it um and
it's like important that people just
focus on
on like what's important to them and you
know just without
just going to without digressing too far
off that discipline thing
um i just said like last lockdown
i want to improve my fitness my
education and my family
and like fitness is is pretty simple
right
you know you do whatever exercise
routine you go for a run you pick up
something that you're going to get
better at
um education it was like right i'm gonna
learn some new stuff i started trying to
play
play the guitar um started listening to
more podcast audio books
started reading started researching
stuff that i'm interested in
and then family was like like speak to
my family more often make sure that
they're safe
and speak to a friend at least once
they're like
chat to people that because you get off
that conversation you feel better
you feel better than you did when you
went on um
but yeah like discipline uh going back
to discipline it's
you know like i think i always say it's
like your choice
to be more disciplined um and you can
you can you can read books and you can
listen to podcasts
podcasts and stuff for motivation but
essentially you've got to make the
choice that
that you want more discipline in your
life um
and once you've made that choice then
you've just got to implement things in
that
that gives you discipline and that might
just be
you know just setting an alarm clock you
know if you're off work at the minute
and you just don't set an alarm clock
and you wake up at nine o'clock just set
that alarm clock for seven or eight or
whatever it is and just get up with an
alarm clock
every day and then try and make that
alarm clock earlier like at the minute
i'm trying to get up at
6 00 6 30 because it's starting to get
light and start doing stuff like go out
for a walk and just commit to going out
for a walk
and then you know commit to an exercise
regime commit to reading one book every
like every month
just start like trying to set yourself
these small tasks
i read in a book once um
and this guy was trying to talk about
discipline and he said
you know one thing he said just if you
put a plate in the in the
in the um in the sink every time you put
a plate in the sink or anything
wash it and just don't leave it there
and it's like these little like
hacks or tricks or tips that you do
every day
build discipline into your life and that
those small ones then
flow into the bigger ones that you that
you need discipline for whether it's
training for a marathon whether it's
researching for a job interview or
whatever it is
these little ones feed into it yeah how
you do anything
is how you do everything i love that
pain chris
one of the one of the things that i used
as a little tip for people and
it's timely for me to remind everyone
who's listening of it again
the best heuristic i've found
to make sure that you stay on track
during lockdown
by having a plan is to ask yourself now
what would have had to have happened by
the end of lockdown
for me to look back on lockdown and
consider it a success
just after this podcast finishes like
just take a little bit of time and think
about i'll do it as being
jay continue to chat [ __ ] to each other
just think like what would have had to
have happened by the end of this period
for you to look back on it and it be a
success so for me
i have a target for the podcast i want
to hit 100 000 subs on youtube before
christmas
if i do that and if everything else
continues to tick over i'll be happy
that's one thing
last time it was like i wanted to build
a website and and start a newsletter
and um record three times a week like
that was it
and it's easy for us to get caught up
believing that we should do more could
have done more
when you don't have a tightly defined
target
it always feels like you've missed
because
you're always going to feel like you
could have done more what it should have
could
and like i say that's that's my that's
my best question for everyone who's
listening who's thinking about that
so next next up is opportunity and
you lay out a three-stage process for
opportunities
would you be able to take us through
that yeah so this the three-stage
process is
and exploit so encounters all about
putting yourself in that position where
you can
um encounter those um
opportunities so that's like how you've
got your life set up right
um for me you know the biggest one was
going into the military because i put
myself in a position where i could
experience other things and other
experiences
and that you know that put me in a
position to
be around people that had gone on
selection and been in the special forces
and
and that's when that you know although
you volunteer for it it's an opportunity
um you know and then the second one is
recognized so
you know if i think it's something in my
life um so the everest expeditions right
they came from one um
you know encountering that opportunity
to recognizing what that opportunity was
and at the time it was supposed to be a
an expedition to k2
and you know i'm massive on gut feel if
something
feels good and it feels like it's going
to change my life for the better
then i take that opportunity um but you
have to
you have to almost it's like a muscle
right the more of these opportunities
you take and
they lead you down these like crazy and
different paths
the more you you're able to recognize
them when they they fall on
you know on your doorstep and then it's
exploiting them which is
you know exactly what it is it's right
where can i take this opportunity
because
we all know that when we take
opportunities
or when we when we agree to things or
whatever it is
they they always open more doors further
down the line
and then those doors open more doors
down the line and before you know it
you know you've met some other people
you've done some other
stuff in your life and you've gone down
a completely different path than
what you'd set out to do that's one of
the things that i've been thinking about
recently obviously this little trip that
i've taken out to dubai
um i decided the the sunday
after the saturday that lockdown was
announced got a pcr test on the monday
for kovid
packed on the tuesday and left on the
wednesday um
i'm not always like a perfect bastion
of immediate action i suppose um you
know we get stuck in
everyone gets stuck in ruts and i'm no
different
um but that single decision the
opportunity for me to be able to get
away before lockdown came in
and then the single time commitment has
had
multiple downstream changes like it's
literally the difference between me
being here
with it being like 9 p.m at night
in 30 degree heat off on a yacht party
tomorrow on the biggest yacht in dubai
or me being in the uk and doing the life
that i had there
and i love the life that i have in the
uk and it's very productive but i've
done it all this year
so yes recognizing opportunities and i
think committing to them
that the exploit part is is really
important a lot of people will see
something and not realize that it is an
opportunity
uh or not decide to commit to it and
it's trite to say it but it's very true
that
we often i would say that more of our
regrets
certainly lean toward things that we
chose not to do rather than things that
we chose to do
we as creatures are on the side of
stagnation
i think naturally 100 our tendency
is to the status quo uh i'm i'm scared
about that new cave next door i'm scared
about that new bush over there i'm
scared about that new tribe in the next
valley
and you just roll that forward to the
21st century when
we really don't have anything to be
afraid of i like covet and
and like mad political elections and
stuff like that but
really day-to-day your
safety the water the heat of being
somewhere sheltered
all that sort of stuff all of those
fears have gone and they've become
that worry around new experiences
has been transmuted into
people being concerned about all manner
of
small things that really don't matter
you know think about like
anyone's slightly anxious mum it's like
that person like oh have you got your
coat on have you got your gloves have
you got
you know that kind of approach i think
is just a
a maladapted evolutionary uh uh
heritage coming through yeah but like
you know that's the that's like a lot of
people right in the world
and it's you know that whole like
wrapping people up in cotton wool and
um you know even just you know we all
live like you said right we all live in
these
buildings these four walls like we we
don't
know what it feels like to feel rain on
our face at night time or
be cold like we're rarely cold as human
beings right
like we rarely have to walk long
distances or fend for our own food and
and you know it's like it all creates a
softer human being
and and it's almost like what you're
seeing now as a result is
people get so offended because they've
got almost this
free time to become offended by some by
things
whereas do you know like if you had to
fend for your food and get all this kind
of stuff it's like
it's like you wouldn't have that that
time available to be able to do that
kind of stuff
massively so man i realized this at the
beginning of the first lockdown
when covid came about um in the absence
of a real crisis
we create our own and in the presence of
a real crisis we re-center our
priorities
the fact that when everything's so
comfortable
and all of our problems are problems of
surplus not problems of scarcity at the
moment
so think about the fact that we have too
much information too much food
too much um spare time
even to concern ourselves with this
stuff and all of those problems are now
causing stuff
diabetes people being overweight
technology addiction so on and so forth
and yeah we're maladapted to the
environment and it's
increasingly why you see people
going back to a more paleolithic style
of life
you know people that choose the
minimalist movement now
is a 21st century uh hark back to people
trying to reduce the amount of clutter
that's in their lives trying to reduce
that amount of surplus
so yeah it's um well it's you've only
got to look at like the amount of people
that are entering
iron man like iron mans and ultra
triathlons and that kind of stuff these
days because
like the human body needs suffering
like it needs it needs some kind of
suffering because
we've had it all our life right and you
take all that suffering away and make it
make an easy life for yourself and you
know everything's
at the touch of a button and
everything's so easily accessible it's
it's not you know that's why that's why
you see like depression and suicide up
at such a high rate
because people just don't know how to
suffer anymore
that's an interesting that's an
interesting insight on it i think that
you
you're probably correct there that
voluntary exposure to
gradually increasing levels of
discomfort
will make you more tolerant to it over
time um
there's a really interesting study that
they did on
children babies infants um so i think
that
if you are a child who has i want to say
eczema
or some other skin condition you are
also predisposed to having peanut
allergy
uh i think that it's one of the it's one
of the highlights right so what they did
was they
they took children who had the
eczema particular problem and
voluntarily split them into two
different groups
group one was allowed to have
rice puffs that had a very very slight
peanut coating dusting on them
and the the other group was kept free of
nuts
the argument is that most parents that
learn about eczema
would hear that if your child has eczema
there is a
increased risk of them being allergic to
peanuts therefore they will keep them
away from
absolutely everything that may have nuts
in it and what they did was they tracked
these children
over time and the end result of the
study
was that the children who had been
voluntarily exposed to the peanuts had a
25
peanut allergy and the children who had
been
kept free of all of the peanut dust had
a 75
peanut allergy yeah it's wacky
it's crazy man voluntarily exposing
yourself to things that are going to be
difficult like why why are people doing
cold showers
at the moment it's the ultimate
doing something just because it hurts
there's some physiological adaptations
which are good and you get a bit of a
buzz off it it's like having a big
a big fat cup of coffee that lasts for
about 20 minutes which is nice
but for the most part it's people
avoiding that flinch
you know like why are you scared of
getting in the cold shower like really
why are you scared and it's a very
interesting
uh internal battle to watch yourself go
through because you know it's going to
be cold
but it's not going to kill you it's not
even going to hurt you it's just going
to be a little bit uncomfortable
so yeah i think that's definitely
something that i would
um i would try and encourage in
as many people as i can so we've got
we've got the word soldier
self-opportunity leadership danger
intelligence excellence and resilience
the ones that we got left which one's
your favorite can we go into that one
uh i think
i would say
call me off guard
[Laughter]
do you know what like i'd say that i'd
say probably my favorite self
um more soaks i'm quite
i can get quite deep on myself and um
i'm quite interested by human psychology
and
how we all fit into the world and um
like being able to pull out your true
potential and
understand where like people fit into
teams and that
that we're not all different um and in
the book i
talk about personality testing um in
specific the myers-briggs personality
testing
and you know it's something that
everyone should go and do just to find
out
just to find out what their personality
type is because
i think a lot of people just float
through the universe just not
diving deep on on what kind of person
they actually are so
when you actually do a test and get a
result it's it's
a more you kind of it gives you a more
realization of what you're actually like
yeah i think
it's quite uncomfortable for a lot of
people to do self-reflection especially
if you're not used to it and i i get
that i
would probably guess that a lot of the
people who are listening
skew towards a very different sort of
type of person they're going to be
incredibly uh
introspective they're going to do a lot
of self-inquiry just because of the
the sort of guests i have on but
i there is no amount of money on the
planet that you could pay me to stop
thinking
about my internal monologue like it's
the single
the single most fascinating thing that i
do
um yeah agree i love working on
motivations and i do it in other people
as well
and when you get to a particular level
of competence with yourself you're able
to help other people and that feels
really really good
you know that you you kind of kind of
like you were talking before about
voluntary discomfort so okay i'm gonna
go through
a little bit of discomfort thinking
about some
stuff that happened in my past that i
don't like or thinking about a thing
that i really wish that i
attribute i wish i didn't have whatever
and
after you work through that and you
realize that it didn't kill you
you can then help other people around
you to do it um
it's really it's a beautiful use of time
man i think i think that's a good show
definitely like what i really love doing
on myself
is trying to understand why i make
decisions
or why i do certain things and just
going like
just doing the deep dive and and trying
to understand
like why i'm so hell bent on being
like fit and healthy and a psychopath
that goes up to the top of everest twice
yeah like things like that like what is
like what is my absolute reason for
doing that and there's probably
a load of different reasons but i kind
of i quite enjoy having a very
um objective or pulled out point of view
of everything and just try and
even observe other people and just be
like right like why why do why does
why does so many people sit in front of
the tv and listen to the news and listen
to the media and
like live on it's every word as
though that's the truth and you know
just trying to have a very
abstract point of view on absolutely
everything that goes on through the
through myself and through through the
world yeah
i think uh the rationalist movement
which is going on at the moment uh
lesswrong.com and the slate star codex
that i'm a massive fan of two
two fantastic blogs i think that a big
part of that
is people trying to bring a little bit
of order to chaos because if you leave
your life to be
um guided by the paths of least
resistance you often end up in a place
not only
that you don't want to be but that you
didn't even mean to get to
you know like you can very easily live a
life that you regret without even
realizing that you're walking down the
path
and um not quite easily yeah yeah that's
something that everybody should be
fearful of
you know like we're made to like live
this easy life aren't we like
you will see you will search out the
easiest way of doing things
every time unless you're aware that
you're doing those things
yeah so underneath everything actually
there's a little bit of a source code
that people should lean into discomfort
wherever they can find it
and the more that you can get used to
leaning into it you know
remember as well the reason that you go
to the gym
is for the discomfort the discomfort is
a signal that you're doing the thing
you're there to do
it's not the thing that you're supposed
to oh this hurts in the gym therefore
i'll stop doing it's like no no no
that that is why you're there so people
are used to it right you know annie used
to talk about the
how much he loved the pump and in the
gym people are aware that that's why
okay i did a thing and the outcome of
that thing was a little bit of
discomfort but that's what i'm chasing
because it identifies growth
the body rewards you for that as well
right the body makes you feel good with
endorphins
that just needs mapping onto other areas
of life i had ali abdullah
not long ago was a youtuber that focuses
on learning and productivity
and he nailed it he was like learning is
supposed to be hard
if it's not difficult you're not
learning yeah exactly the same as the
gym and the same thing goes for
everything so yeah i think
i definitely think there's a unifying
thread across a lot of other stuff
the last question for you man what is
the biggest insight
that you wish more people knew about
life
i think we just covered it that one
discomfort just
yeah just just search out
difficult things and
the reward you you know you'll soon get
the reward that it brings you
i love that i love that and i agree as
well so soldier will be linked in the
show notes below
if people want to check you out to go
and see some other stuff about you where
should they go jay
uh so mainly instagram uh so it's j
double underscore morton
uh also on twitter and facebook probably
less active on those two
and i've got a website as well uh just
it's jmortonofficial.com
fantastic everything will be linked in
the show notes below what's next for you
there man obviously final final thing
you've got
this period to sit at home and plan some
mad adventures
oh were you doing some race what's the
race uh
yeah so i'm racing for a car team called
prague next year
um which is again like fairly new to me
the whole motorsport thing so
at the minute just trying to get as much
seat time and as much learning
and practice in cars and tracks around
the uk as possible
um and then yeah so i'll start i think
my first race is next
march what's the car what's the vehicle
it's called the prague
r1 it's a it's a full aero race car so
you can't buy one and race it on the
road um it's
it's strictly a track car but it's full
aero so
you know if you think of f1 f1 has got
an aero system which means that the
faster you drive it
the more it sticks to the ground um so
this is the same in this car the faster
you drive it
the more grip you produce um it's got a
350 brake horsepower renault turbo
engine in
and it weighs 600 600 kg [ __ ]
the bed so yeah it's a it's a machine uh
it's like a
little little single cockpit um
like a little single cockpit car kind of
looks like a smaller
lemon car it's like a rocket ship that's
had wheels attached to it
exactly exactly
all right man well look good luck with
that i hope that you have a very good
lockdown and uh thank you so much for
your time
cheers chris take care
[Music]